I know this videos a little later than
usual I am NOT going to apologize I just
got back from a very one and it was
awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
don't worry they'll be as complete a
video recap as I can do of Gallifrey one
though that will probably go up in the
breakroom you'll get noticed when it
goes off but for right now we need to
talk about the latest episode of Doctor
Who the haunting of Villa did did de
bunda thing I can't remember exactly
what it said I don't remember them ever
singing in dialogue so I am NOT gonna
look it up because I'm lazy so this was
an interesting one partly because of my
experience of watching it which was that
I think I'm allowed to say this now they
asked us to not send it out on social
media initially but we actually got it
screened at Gallifrey 1 as the lead-up
to the closing ceremony so I got to
watch it in this massive room surrounded
by God I don't even know how many
laughing hollering gasping cheering
Doctor Who fans which look if you're
gonna watch an episode of Doctor Who I
highly recommend that way of doing it
now one could consider that maybe that
colors my opinions in a positive
direction and I will put that forward as
a possibility but then again I'm also
gonna have criticism so I don't think
that is gonna influence me too much one
way or the other but let's talk about
this thing so we've got another
historical set up so the historical is
this series and honestly if I'm gonna
level with you the historical zuv the
Chippenham run in general have worked
better for me way more often than the
historical episodes usually do not
always and I do have various issues some
of them but I no longer have the dread
going into his historical episode with a
celebrity historical figure that I used
to in the Moffatt and Davies era cuz I
really didn't like the over
congratulatory feel in the format of
those I just I never really cared for
them I'm enjoying the historical is
quite a bit during the Chibnall period
so if nothing else I feel like he's
doing those at least consistently better
so I suppose
that's something I've got to give the
guy so this is set ostensibly the night
that Lord Byron Percy Shelley Mary
Shelley and two other people whose names
I don't remember because I don't know
enough about history and again I'm not
gonna look it up because I'm lazy all
our trading ghost stories and they
basically dare each other to come up
with the scariest story they can and
Mary Shelley goes and writes
Frankenstein so that's our starting
setup that that's the events that we're
coming in on but things don't go quite
as planned which is part of what I like
about this as a historical piece I don't
like when the historical set pieces feel
more like a walking tour of a major
figures life that I would say the
weakest historical of the Chippendale
era was the witch hunters because it
read a lot of times like a Wikipedia
entry on King James you know interesting
guy but they couldn't find a way to
weave a him into the story he just kind
of shows up and we get an info dump on
him this felt much more integrated we
get to see the dynamics between these
people we get much better sense of them
as people as opposed to simply
historical figures which I thought was
cool the performances we're all good
I liked the vibe on this doctor who you
know it can try for scary and often does
I do like the gothic horror when Doctor
Who goes for and it doesn't go for it as
much as in the modern era there were
chunks of classic that are very gothic
and I like that feeling this I like the
use of illogical architecture you know
you got you exited or in a room you come
back in right into the exact same room I
like that sort of stuff and it's well
presented visually here they did a
really good job with the owner the
little flashes of light and oh did I see
something that you want to have and
anything that is ostensibly a ghost
story so props for their nicely
presented I really enjoyed
Fletcher who was I was a butler he said
some other title which I didn't quite
catch and don't know what it was so
forgive me forgetting that I'm sort of
shrugging my shoulders and giving up on
getting a lot of specific details right
I I'm starting to feel bad about that
but I'm still gonna plow ahead
I loved him there's so much personality
and that guy just the way he reacted to
these wealthy spoiled people around him
and just this look of especially where
he gets he gets told not asked told he's
gonna be a second in this guy's stupid
superfluous duel he's suddenly decide
he's gonna do it do and he's just back
there I love that guy so much that's
gonna come back around though hold on to
that so once we get into and I would
give a spoiler warning but like I said
I'm getting this review up a little bit
later that I normally would so I would
think everyone who really cares has
already seen the thing but consider that
your warning anyway my my feelings are
overall very positive and about to start
talking about the specifics that were a
bit of a surprise when they show it up
so here we go
belong Cybermen I did think that that
was going to somehow come up in this one
because I figured you know doctor who
has tied Cybermen to Mary Shelley's
Frankenstein before they did it in Big
Finish with I think it was actually a
couple of Eighth Doctor stories I
haven't actually listened to those ones
yet but I know they exist so that link
has already been explored some degree in
Doctor Who and you know that just felt
like something that would get planted
here to set up the two-part button
presumably two-part finale that we're
heading into but I expected it to play a
bit like the master reveal at the end of
utopia which is a tag at the end to lead
us into the next thing it was a bit more
integrated into the story here because
the Cybermen or at least what he's after
is a port is the primary cause of what's
going on in the first place so there's
that and then he shows up a lot earlier
into this story that I would have
expected oh you should have heard the
cheers go up in the hall haha when a
Cyberman showed up I really like this
Cyberman so there's a couple of things I
really like about this um I I would
never want what we see here to become
the standard or Cyberman which is part
of why I like these all bust it up and
you get the sense this is not standard
this is not what they're supposed to be
like which is part of why I was able to
just roll with it and really enjoy him
like the idea that he is converted
enough to be following directives but
like they haven't gotten all the
emotional inhibitors gone he gets
frustrated he gets angry he has glee and
VIN presumed victory
I like seeing those kinds of emotions
come out of a Cyberman and I really kind
of dig that idea and also it really
makes me this is like ahead can anything
I'm about to talk about but I liked that
it made me think this it made me think
because generally if the emotional
inhibitors don't work what we've seen is
that the entire Cybermen apparatus
breaks down it either stops functioning
or it freakin blows up so to have
someone who the emotional inhibitors are
still working still toeing the line and
following orders it makes me wonder in
interesting ways like what kind of
person was this guy that even with his
emotions intact he's not rebelling hmm
and that mate now that's me filling in
blanks and maybe so maybe that's
projecting more depth on to him than is
actually supposed to be there but I
liked thinking about that I enjoyed that
there was a really interesting moment
now I've heard more than a little bit
over the last two series people talking
about there being some sort of chemistry
between Yaz and the doctor and I'm not
gonna say that I didn't see it at all
but I was kind of like I think you're
making a mountain out of a molehill
there was a nice moment here that I
actually quite enjoyed for it's sort of
starting to deliver on the idea of that
while having it be a moment rooted in
character and rooted in a character
interaction which is Yeahs relating to
this woman who you know it has a thing
for Lord Byron because why wouldn't you
and you know she says you know I've I
know someone to who's like that the more
you find out the less you know and it's
never said explicitly that it's the
doctor um it's my hope that that'll be
made a little I'm not
let me back up I don't actually ship the
two of them I don't want them to
actually become a couple but you know if
we're gonna do anybody has a crush on
the doctor I'm I'm okay with it being
yaz I do hope that if that is where
they're going to at least confirm
slightly more explicitly because well I
think it's hard to say that she's
talking about anybody other than the
doctor um you know there's a there's
right now the opening for people who
wish to believe that maybe she's
thinking about Ryan or there's also the
conspiracy nuts who seemed to insist
that she's talking about the master
because they think she's somehow a
secret double it I don't buy that theory
like for the record I really don't but
until we get confirmation that's gonna
be in the air as well in the fandom but
I did like that moment and I like that
it felt like a natural organic her
connecting with this other woman you
know doing something that is a police
technique to find a way to connect with
someone who you're basically trying to
talk down from something now granted
she's not like trying to talk her off a
ledge she's just trying to you know help
her gather herself but it made sense for
her to talk about that it did not feel
shoehorned in at all and I liked that
moment quite a bit um so towards the
tail end there was one there was one key
moment I did not like at all and this is
this is gonna sound weird ly nitpicky
but it really did bother me heavily and
I have a feeling I'm one of the only
people's gonna be bothered by this or at
least gonna be bothered by this in the
way that I'm bothered by this that
happens sometimes and also it's like
cushioned in the middle of a moment that
I otherwise liked so let's talk about
the doctor herself I feel like we're
getting some interesting glimpses at
what it is she's kind of been avoiding
showing because she's been squirrely
with her companions about how much of
herself she reveals to them and that's
not actually new I didn't really notice
it previous series but I definitely
noticed it this series and looking back
she was kind of dodging stuff a bit last
series and I feel like we started to get
a glimpse at what is behind her evasions
the anger that is there the just you
know the fire that can be unleashed and
you know when she laid into two Ryan and
when she said this is not a flat team
structure this is a mountainous pyramid
and I am at the top that was a harsh
moment and I found it to be a really
interesting one coming from this doctor
in particular especially at this point
in time however in the middle of that
moment um you know where she's arguing
with everybody about whether or not
they're gonna give the lone Cyberman
what it wants because obviously the most
of the comedian's arguing no you can't
do that dark Jack said not to do it and
doctor again great little moment Jack's
not here
you know said is is looking at
personally going I don't think I can
condemn this one person to death which
is a stance and a decision that's very
consistent for the doctor that's a
decision the doctor is made repeatedly
across incarnations the saving of who is
here now at the risk of others later in
in the hope that in preserving their own
conscience they will be able to stop
whatever they may have inadvertently set
in motion in the meantime that's very
dr. ish but there was something about
the specific wording of her defense of
that choice particularly when she was
shouting down Ryan because where I made
the point you know it's it's just one
man weighed against billions now I
didn't expect the doctor to not argue
that point with him again because that's
the side of the debate she's always land
on and she argue the point that the
doctors consistently argued but when she
started going off on how valuable
Shelley was and how valuable his were
were and how his words inspired and how
if he dies there are ripple effects that
could change the entire world that Ryan
comes from now I don't have a problem
with her pointing that out in general
but I do have a problem with the context
of that being pointed out in this
specific story and remember I said we
were gonna come back to Fletcher well
here's what we're gonna come back to him
and also to the maid because I had the
thought earlier in the episode I like
how much more fleshed out the Fletcher
and and the I don't know if she was a
maid or a wet nurse or both but the
woman who tried to hide the baby
how much more fleshed out they were and
that they weren't they initially I
thought maybe they're not even gonna
kill them because they I'm like they're
fleshed out and I'm really enjoying the
presence they did both end up dying but
it was it I did appreciate that I felt
like it was given more weight than the
death of secondary characters often are
and Doctor Who but something really
really irked me that in a story that has
already killed two people that the
doctor is gonna make this big argument
about how you can't let Percy Shelley
die because of the ripple effects
now obviously the doctor couldn't
prevent the death of those other two
people but the fact that the it felt to
me like the episode was trying was using
her to make its point which again is
something typical of Doctor Who even
prior to this frickin he'll look back at
the Zygon inversion speech again but
there's something about two people have
died there has been no mention
whatsoever about their importance their
impact on the world their loss but we
have to stop and point out how important
Percy Shelley is his words whatever
because he's the important historical
figure and there's something that rang
very hollow about the doctor making the
every life is important argument in
defense of the famous
historical poet and not even a passing
mention of the people who had already
died which while not explicitly
implicitly labels them as unimportant
and this shows have it again going back
way before going back to the freaking
classic era this shows habit of very
casually killing off for a lack of a
better term the servant class is really
starting to bug me and it really came to
a head in this one and more to the point
when she said you know words matter I
had I been watching it alone I would
have sworn at the screen it's not
because I don't believe that sentiment
and I'm gonna have to be clarified this
really specifically because I've said in
the past that I like stories about
stories I like stories about the power
and the and the strength and the
importance of stories and storytelling
however there's an asterisk on that
which is I'm very over the aggrandizing
and placing up on a pillar of the author
I like things about the value of stories
I don't like things that basically put
the author a writer on a pedestal as
being more important more valuable more
influential more inspirational and I say
that as somebody with aspirations of
writing and it's not because writers
aren't influential but I it really
bothers me and things like this because
it feels that specific line to me felt
less like something the doctor was
saying than something the writers were
saying and when writers are grand izing
the role of the writer
that's masturbatory writers can
aggrandize the power of stories without
necessarily praising the existence of
the writer themselves but they didn't do
that they yeah they failed to not do
that here I'm so many contradictions I'm
but you can tell I'm frustrated by that
and I've it's just so patting on the
back
are important it was and it annoys me
how annoyed I am cuz it was a relatively
small moment in an episode that I
otherwise honestly really enjoyed I love
the vibe I thought the performances were
great Graham had some awesome moments I
like that we've got an acknowledgement
of Ryan's dyspraxia which I feel like we
haven't had explicitly brought up in a
while so it's nice to get that
reestablished there's a lot that I like
I like the idea that Time Lords can I
must presumably have this power
themselves and like she kind of grants
it to Shelley sort of role for it in
their own timeline to see how they die
like that's an interesting wrinkle I and
I buy it like that's neat and I'm really
curious to see how it sets up to where
things go and the finale I'm there's so
much I like but just this friggin little
nugget of failing to acknowledge the the
death and the loss of anyone other than
a writer who doesn't die at least not in
the story and also explicitly calling
out the value of writers so like anybody
because I know there are some people who
watch my channel with aspirations of
authorship yet just don't do that I
don't say you can't think that about you
and your writing or whatever but don't
put it in the text please it's so
self-indulgent and those were two
moments that came basically back-to-back
that really bugged me in an otherwise
very enjoyable episode uh-huh like I
said it bothers me how much it bothered
me because I'm pretty sure I spent more
time talking about this like a minute
worth of stuff than the entire rest of
the thing and I liked almost the entire
rest of the thing oh well that's that
that's what you get for being nitpicker
when tiny things really latch into you
but the haunting of villa didn't but
what do you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something on down in
the comments let's talk about it bunch
of stuff to do besides you know all the
things like and subscribe and share this
and support me
John if you feel like helping me paying
my bills that is immensely appreciated
that was how he was able to afford to go
to Gallifrey won in the first place so
yay for that but you know you also don't
have to do any of that because end of
the day you're the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]